in this video we'll talk about the
neuromuscular Junction neuromuscular
Junction is simply the synapse between
the nerve and the muscle it's a
specialized synapse at the neuromuscular
Junction the action potential or
stimulation from the nerve terminal
reaches the muscle and it would lead to
the muscle contraction
the end part of the motor neurons are
known as botons which basically
innervate the muscle
we are looking at one nmj or one
particular synapse and in this case the
blue is the presynaptic part or the
nerve terminal and the Orange is the
muscle which is the post synapse in this
case and the junction between them is
basically marked by the synaptic cleft
where the neurotransmitters would be
released in this case in in mammalian
situation or in vertebrate neuromuscular
Junction the key neurotransmitter is
acetylcholine so these are cholinergic
synapses
acetylcholine is generated from acetyl
COA with the help of the enzyme
acetylcholine acetyl transference
and from there acetylcholine is loaded
onto synaptic vesicle with the help of
vesicular acetylcholine transporter once
loaded in these vesicles they would
eventually be fused at the nerve
terminal when the action potential comes
and it would be released in the synaptic
lift
so now we would look at this uh
particular phenomena in bit more details
so we would break it down like
presynaptic and postsynaptic events and
try to understand the nuts and bols of
it
so the nerve terminal
is shown in this particular diagram and
you can see the action potential is
reaching the nerve terminal so once the
action potential reach the North
Terminal it allows the voltage-gated
calcium channel to be opened and this
leads to severe level of calcium influx
into the post synapse so the
extracellular side has calcium in order
of let's say millimolars whereas the
intracellular side generally has calcium
in order of nanomolars so anyway there
is a huge jump of calcium level in the
synaptic end and this calcium leads to
the vesicular snare and the target
membranes near Fusion via a complicated
Machinery which I am not going to talk
in bit more details here
so and that lead to the vesicle Fusion
which allow the neurotransmitter to be
released in the synaptic cleft
in this case the neurotransmitter is
acetylcholine but here is one thing when
acetylcholine is released in the
synaptic cleft it doesn't stay there
forever right otherwise the overall
response would be overwhelming so in
that case there are enzymes known as
acetylcholine esterase that can break
down acetylcholine and clear that
response anyway these are the
presynaptic events what happens in the
post synapse when the neurotransmitter
is present in the synaptic cleft
so let's look at the postsynaptic event
again just to give you an idea the
action potential reach the nerve
terminal and stimulates the release of
acetylcholine and here we are zooming
into one nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor which are nothing but
ligand-gated ION channel so as their
ligand-gated ION channel acetylcholine
binds into specific ligand binding
pocket that leads to a conformational
change in these receptor
and the acetylcholine receptor basically
opens up and allows cationic influx into
the post synapse that makes the
postsynaptic membrane more positive and
there is a voltage change this is red as
an postsynaptic potential change
and these are the post-synaptic event
now since we understand the postsynaptic
potentials biology let's look at a
little bit about the
electrophysiological signatures so
people generally record using sharp
electrodes from the muscle and once they
record it they would see a change in the
potential and this is either there is a
change in current or there is a change
in potential
change in current is known as the
excitatory postsynaptic current or epsc
look at the axis you can always see Pico
amps and milliseconds in the axis so
that would give you a sense that this is
current
and there could be also excitatory
postsynaptic potential this is a
potential change
let me remind you that postsynaptic
potential is not equivalent to action
potential postsynaptic potential is a
graded potential now postsynaptic
potential does change the membrane
voltage and makes it more positive and
even it crosses the action potential
threshold there would be a action
potential firing
now in the synaptic cleft there are lot
of acetylcholine acetylcholine binds to
the acetylcholine receptors which made
the membrane more positive now when
there is a surge in the voltage it
allows the voltage-gated uh other
channels in the muscle membrane to open
that allows further influx of the
cations
now eventually when the voltage reaches
the action potential threshold there
would be action potential in this case
this is not a nerve so the post synapse
doesn't fire an action potential like a
nerve but the response or the readout of
the response is contraction of the
muscle fiber that is the postsynaptic
response now let us understand the same
thing using a little bit
electrophysiological signatures let's
say there is a
postsynaptic potential which is having a
magnitude like this but it is well below
the action potential threshold so action
potential is not fired or muscle is not
contracted in this case
even if the second uh
particular PSP is there it is not
crossing the action potential threshold
in a third scenario there is a stronger
stimulus which leads to a bigger jump
which allowed the action potential
threshold to be crossed and there you
can see the action potential is fired
right or the muscle is contracted so
this is the overall idea about the
postsynaptic potentials now let's talk
about things that has gone wrong in
context of neuromuscular Junction one of
the disease known as myasthenia gravis
which is a chronic autoimmune disease
and it is characterized by weakness and
muscle fatigue so it occurs when the
immune system mistakenly targets the
acetylcholine receptors and affect the
neuromuscular Junction
so here is the control side here you
here you can see the the nerve terminal
has a quite a lot of release of
acetylcholine now in the right hand side
you can see the myasthenia gravis where
there are specific plasma cells
secreting antibodies against the
acetylcholine receptor
so first it hinders with the
acetylcholine binding with the receptor
second of all these particular
antibodies can fix complement and damage
the postsynaptic membrane that can lead
to inflammation and that can lead to a
weaker stimulation of the muscle lead to
muscle fatigue and other problems
there is another symptom known as lumbar
Eton syndrome in this case the immune
system mistakenly attacks the
voltage-gated calcium channel in the
nerve cells
so if you remember that the vgccs that
are present in the prison apps are
crucial for the vesicle Fusion events in
the presynaptic terminal so in the
presynaptic terminal with when these
particular channels are non-functional
there would be a problem in case of the
vesicle Fusion that lead to a lesser
synaptic release and the overall
neurotransmitter level would be less in
the synaptic cleft
that would lead to a weaker stimulation
I mean weaker kind of stimulation and
there would be muscle fatigue or less
functionality in the muscle
now there are specific toxins that can
affect the neuromuscular Junction here
we would take the examples of two or
three so in this case the first toxin is
botulinum toxin which is derived from
the bacteria clostridium botulinum and
this botulinum toxin can lead to muscle
paralysis anyway this enough specific
dose is used for the Cosmetic Surgery as
well the botox is very common among the
people who are in the glamor world
now in this case in control scenario we
talked about the v-snare and the t-snare
right the Wiesner and the t-snare lead
to the vesicle Fusion in the prison apps
and that lead to this lead to the
neurotransmitter release in the synaptic
cleft
now bottling toxin actually breaks the
t-snare and we snare interaction and
that lead to a faulty Fusion of the
particular vesicles
now toxins that can affect neuromuscular
Junctions could be diverse there is
another toxin known as bangaru toxin
this is derived from a snake and this
neck toxin also affect the neuromuscular
Junction lead to muscle paralysis but in
a different way in this case Bangalore
toxin uh binds with the acetylcholine
receptor and prevents the acetylcholine
to be bound with the receptor that means
not too much cation can be influx
through these acetylcholine receptor
even if there is a muscle a nerve
stimulation this lead to a muscle
paralysis so this is how we can
understand that there are different
toxins which can act in different
mechanisms to regulate the functionality
of the neuromuscular Junction that
pretty much summarize this video on
neuromuscular Junction this is just an
overview but in other subsequent videos
we would be delving into details about
the neuromuscular Junction
so let's get notes and flashcards for
your preparation you can get it from
Facebook page or my Instagram page the
links are provided in the description
don't forget to follow us on Facebook or
Instagram
you can support our Channel using super
tanks which is a heart-shaped icon with
the dollar in it it's it's present in
the right hand side bottom corner of any
video you can contribute using paytm
PayPal UPI or anything
also you can support us in patreon you
can follow our Channel also the nerd
medic Channel which has exclusive
medical contents so see you in the next
video